welcome back to new rockstars it's me mt
and with the release of four love and
thunder coming only a few months away
this summer the first trailer for
natalie portman's long-awaited swing at
gore the god butcher as the mighty thor
should be coming any day now like any
day now come on come on kevin start it
up and huge thanks to the sirius xm app
for sponsoring this video but while we
do know that christian bale is going to
be absolutely wrecking gods in 4-4 what
we don't know as of yet is exactly what
will be fueling the flames of gore's
gory grievances with the gods of asgard
and the guardians of the galaxy and
whether or not the newest and biggest
mcu revelation of the eternals and
celestial's cataclysmic cosmic roles in
the universe could factor in but lucky
for us in the comic book movie world
nothing is faster than the speed of toys
so it should not surprise us that the
thor love and thunder themed lego set
would be our first look at the menacing
gore the god butcher but what can we
learn about the mighty jane foster's
upcoming struggle to guard the gods from
getting gutted by gore now that gore has
now fallen into the river at lego city
okay like i said before our first look
at christian bale's gourd the god
butcher comes in the form of a pale grey
bald lego gore clashing with a super
charged up and ready to go jane foster
thor officially named the mighty thor by
the information on the lego box with
chris hemsworth's thor odinson keeping
his name as thor because you know that's
his name he just he doesn't lose his
name with of course the most notable
thing about legore the godbutcher other
than you know his piercing red eyes is
of course the large all black blade in
his hands very aptly named all black
which as we know from the marvel comics
is a sword forged from the remnants of
the darkness that existed before the big
bang flooded light into the universe by
the dark primordial god named null now
literally picked up his shadow while the
celestials were invading during the big
bang used the shadow to cut the head off
the first celestial he saw built a forge
inside of that celestial body's torso
and then used the leftover cosmic energy
within that celestial to forge his
all-black sword so he can spend the next
several eons just going out killing more
cosmic colonizers because why wouldn't
you do that he was he was taking a nice
nap before they showed up a nice little
map and by forging all black in the
cosmic energies of a decapitated
celestial's body all black now forever
carries a dark symbiotic connection to
the torso body portion of the celestial
that is now known as nowhere which means
that whoever holds the sword will be
granted the godlike powers of this
basically dead celestial being while its
wielder goes out into the universe
looking for yummy god energy for the all
black sword to absorb and then return
back to nowhere's celestial body for
nourishment probably using 5g or a wi-fi
hotspot or something hey what would you
like to listen to right now to put
yourself in a better mood some mariah
carey pop on a little pop funk maybe
some 50 year old stand up comedy with
the siriusxm app you can listen to all
of that and so much more from your phone
smart speakers computer or anywhere else
you need to hear wonderful sounds i love
to listen to pop 2k when i need some hot
jams for my youth or one of their many
comedy channels for when i need a good
chuckle comedy classics is a great place
to hear red fox shout some really funny
curse words on the siriusxm app you can
enjoy ad-free music channels from every
genre and for every mood they even have
live play-by-play of games from every
major sport and their news and
entertainment channels are super great
find some interviews from your favorite
mcu actors or get the skinny on some
industry gossip and they've got some
great podcasts and lots of serious xm
app originals check out their exclusive
videos and in studio performances and
interviews so find your groove on the
siriusxm streaming platinum plan click
the link below in the description to get
your first three months free when you
subscribe but just make sure to use that
link in the description this is why gore
sword is considered to be the marvel
universe's first symbio because of its
symbiotic relationship with the energies
of nowhere's celestial body you know
much like venom uses eddie brock's
energy and vice versa and this is what
happens to gore who in the comics was
just an alien on a forgotten starving
planet before he bonds with the
all-black necrosword when he comes
across an unconscious no battling a god
a god that ends up being gore's first
ever god kill because gore were so
pissed off at all the gods of the
universe for allowing his entire family
including his pregnant wife and his son
to die from starvation and various
tragedies on that planet like they were
just straight up ignored so with all
blacks cosmic symbiotic connection to
the celestial nowhere body combined with
its innate dark lust to devour souls it
uses gore's anger to continue its former
masters knows mission of killing gods
for its own nourishment because gore
shared the same hatred towards the gods
that null did while all black celestial
collection allows gore the god butcher
to butcher gods for thousands upon
thousands of years as long as he keeps
butchering those gods and absorbing
god's energy for the necrosword like all
black is very much a sentient being in
that manipulating way much like the
enticing bloodlust of all black's cousin
blade the ebony blade that made its
first mcu appearance at the very end of
eternals with the future black knight
dane whitman and hey speaking of
eternals remember how we just learned
how every planet with sentient life on
it are essentially just giant celestial
eggs well crow and the deviant race are
not the only beings in the universe with
a bone to pick with the celestial gods
for you know destroying their homes on a
regular basis oh no because gore you
know giving his tragic origins in the
comics likely suffered a similar tragedy
in the mcu with his family likely having
died with the destruction of his home
planet but has extended his anger at the
celestial gods to also include the
junior gods of the mcu pantheon like the
asgardian and roman gods like king
valkyrie which is what valkyr would be
known as as the lego box says as well as
russell crowe's zeus gods who all very
much likely knew what the celestials
were doing with the universe but just
sat by and let cosmic suffering happen
while you know just eating cheese and
grapes on gold plates on asgard and no
mountain olympus but this lego goat boat
box art also gives us a good look at
james foster's full look as the mighty
thor with a very much worse for wear
cracked mjolnir kind of being hard to
miss on the box with blue glows of power
emitting from the crevices of mjolnir
given the symbolic nature of the dark
primordial ether and how it was
literally feeding off of james foster's
life force in the same way that all
black feeds on souls i can see this
connection being what makes jane foster
the only being in the universe able to
defeat gore the god butcher because i
have a feeling that james foster's brief
time with the ether has given her a
unique resistance to darkness that the
gods of the mcu do not have because i
really don't think the ether ever really
completely left jade foster's body and
the portion of the ether that has
remained has continued to slowly kill
jane foster ever since thor 2 and likely
will unfortunately be the catalyst for
her cancer in the mcu however i also do
believe that it is because of this very
same ether power that's remaining inside
of jane foster that allows mjolnir to be
assembled in the first place because as
we saw in infinity war the reality stone
can basically do whatever it wants on a
molecular level but this could also
explain the interesting design choice on
mcu jane foster's helmet suspiciously
choosing a red insignia instead of the
comic book accurate gold insignia on her
helmet which could be a design choice by
the 411 thunder art team to imply the
red ether's influence on jane's powers
and how it lives inside jane's head and
if you remember from thor the dark world
when malekith does remove the ether from
jane foster's body we do get this zoom
out from jade foster's eyes that seems
to imply that there is a darkness that
remains in her head still and hey
speaking of new thor looks thor
odinson's new look looks suspiciously
similar to that of icaruses the way that
the blue and gold is sort of laid out
and very much seems intentionally
designed after the celestial called the
one above all the kind of forgotten
leader of the celestials in the comics
no one really talks about him anymore
probably because he shares a name with
the other one above all that more people
care about that is basically god they're
two separate characters they're not the
same which sort of implies to me that
thor will likely be given authority by
the celestials themselves at some point
to help jane foster deal with their
pesky or the god butcher problem
outfitting him with a far more durable
armor likely with a little convincing
from his new celestial bff peter quill
who we last see him with at the end of
avengers end game i'm sure those snooty
celestials will be more likely to listen
to a peasant like thor odinson if ego's
son were to say hey it's pretty cool now
these guys are producing other
asgardians
he's not as handsome as people they're
pretty cool
so yes that is my analysis on what i
believe war the god butcher will be
doing in 4-4 but let us know what you
guys think in the comment section below
you can follow me at mastertainment if
you want to see me tweet some really
weird [ __ ] and you know insane theories
but more importantly you can follow new
rockstars wherever we are on social
media just make sure to hit the
notification bell on youtube so you can
get notifications every time we upload a
video and make sure to hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com so you can get really
cool nerd shirts but anyways thank you
guys so much for watching this video i
love you guys so much and i appreciate
you guys taking the time to watch i'll
see you guys later goodbye
[Music]
you